get ready this is not a drill
under extreme circumstances humans can
pull together to overcome great odds but
when confined in a tight space with each
other well
we may not be at our finest
so how would you do if you got trapped
in a grocery store for the rest of your
life
what should you eat first
or who would you eat first
and what would happen when the lights
went out
this is what if and here's what would
happen if you were trapped in a grocery
store for the rest of your life
whether it's a nuclear disaster or a
giant bug invasion whatever's happening
in the outside world has led you and a
small band of survivors to this grocery
store
and this isn't temporary
this fluorescent-lit prison just became
your home for generations to come
that means every decision every resource
and every trip to the bathroom can
affect your lives in the long term
keeping your feelings in check and
managing conflict in this stressful
situation would be your only hope for
survival and sure the shelves are stocks
now but
what will happen when the food is gone
[Music]
so you survived the chaos outside good
job but this wouldn't be the time to
relax
things are about to get challenging
the next 24 hours would be critical to
your survival you and your group would
need to go through the inventory of
perishable foods and decide what you can
preserve and what you intend to eat soon
any waste you make today is a meal you
won't have tomorrow and if you think you
wouldn't waste anything well think about
this the united states alone throws out
450 million kilograms of food every year
you wouldn't have that luxury now but
with the right tools you could turn all
waste including your own into your next
meal
[Music]
we'll come back to that
you would need to dry the fruits and
vegetables you wouldn't eat right away
that can save your veggies for up to six
months and your fruits for up to a year
and if you take a trip a few aisles over
and grab some salt you could dry cure
the proteins applying a coat of salt to
the outside of the meat would remove the
water molecules within it preventing
bacteria from growing
these meats would last up to two months
without refrigeration
as the first week went by the days would
begin to blend
to survive you'd need to split into
groups and divide your work
rotating the chores like cleaning
preserving food and composting would
keep the workload balanced and it would
keep your minds busy so you wouldn't get
burned out
remember this is your life now hey maybe
you and your group can get together to
clean up this store but do you have what
it takes to hunt a killer well whether
it's date night or game night hunt a
killer gives you and your bubble the
chance to come together while solving
puzzles examining clues and decoding
ciphers it's america's number one murder
mystery subscription and it's all
delivered to your front door each
package brings you closer to solving
this murder mystery with audio
recordings case files and the murder
weapons you can work together without
leaving your house to reveal the killer
in this immersive story driven game you
can even interact with 100 000 active
subscribers online in a spoiler-free
community to help you solve these clues
log on to huntakiller.com
what if and use the code what if for 20
off your first box enter the code what
if and join the mystery that has
everyone asking
do you have what it takes to hunt a
killer
okay come on that's enough fun there's a
lot of work left after all you'd need to
rearrange the store and create sections
for sleeping medical care cooking and a
bathroom area and don't count on those
bathroom stalls working forever after
all who knows how long the utilities
might last
during the first month your group would
need to take advantage of the running
water while you still could
your group might decide to use plastic
tubs and garbage cans to save as much
water as possible for future use
this way you could still bathe and water
your plants even when the running water
stops
well running
oh and did i mention that you'll become
a gardener
yeah even with the proper storage and
drying methods the fruits and veggies
wouldn't last forever you would have to
grow plants that can thrive in low light
like mushrooms and potatoes
and if you want your new garden to
survive you'll need to learn how to
compost food waste
we create compost from decomposed
organic material
if your group makes a compost toilet
every bit of waste could help your new
community
known by gardeners as black gold
this substance would keep your garden
growing
that would still be pretty gross though
considering you'd be eating it as part
of your food
[Music]
by the end of your first year in this
grocery store lockdown the comforts of
the outside world would be long gone
running water and electricity would be a
thing of the past
that compost toilet would seem like a
luxury now
you would need to collect and purify
rain water from outside the windows
since the water you collected earlier
wouldn't be drinkable
toxins from the plastic containers could
seep into the water over time and if you
consume these toxins it could damage
your kidneys or liver
stored properly the dried goods inside
the store could last up to 30 years
make sure to check the dates on the
canned goods before eating them
by now all your meats would be gone
or
would they
as the years went on you would sadly
lose more and more members of your group
even with that fully stocked pharmacy
you wouldn't be able to save everyone
medicine expires
and
without any proteins left you might just
have to make some difficult choices
after all you couldn't just leave dead
bodies around the toxic fumes as they
decompose could build up inside the
store
you would need to burn the bodies in a
well-ventilated area
but if one of your group members felt a
little bit like snacking they might take
advantage of this situation
so
don't get too attached to anyone who
might become your dinner later
but
how long could you live like this
well an average supermarket has enough
supplies to keep a human alive for 55
years and with some stores keeping as
many as 3 300 different items on the
shelf your small group could keep
society going even though the outside
world has become a disaster
but
what if your group
couldn't keep it together
what if you became the last person on
earth
well grab your go bag because that's a
story
for another
what if
[Music]
you